[موسيقى]
مناسبه لمراجعه الاساسيات اللي
حكمت المرحله 52 الى 67 اوكي صار مراجعات
كبيره بس ولا مره الا هالمراجعات كانت
بمعنى ما
كانه عم تقول بدنا الغلط اللي وصلنا لهون
بنسبه اعلى يعني
الاشتراك عبد الناصر مش كيفي بدنا اكثر
الاصلاح الخطا بالخطا مش كيفي بدنا اكثر
ولا مره صار في مراجعه فعلا بالكامل
للمسار اللي وصل لل 67 واذا بعده مستمر
[موسيقى]
انا رايي الفرصه الوحيده اللي اتيحت هي
بعد انهيار السلطنه العثمانيه مباشره نعم
بعد انهيار السطر العثمانيه حصل انتدبين
على منطقه المشرق العربي على الاقل
الفرنسي والبريطاني ما حدا بيحب انه ينتذب
عليه او انه يستعمر بالتاكيد لكن قياسه
بمكان قبلها وما حصل بعد
حصلت شغله فينا نسميها فرصه
[موسيقى]
الفرصه ترافات مع
الاستعانه باعيين محليين للحكم هني فيما
بعد تولوا الحكم بعد الاستقلالات ترافات
مع مثل ما كلمه انتداب يعني بتقول مع بناء
شويه احزاب اعلام
نقابه صحوف
فتنه فيها على ادوات العالم الحديث وهي
الفرصه كان ممكن وكان نظري كمان الا هو
تجربه النهضه والافكار النهضويه نعم
نعم فيني اشهد ونقاشات فعلا يعني حاره
يعني مثل موضوع طه حسين الشعب الجاهلي او
علي عبد الرازق هدول كان امكن خوض
هالمعارك الفكريه الكبيره دون ما حدا ما
حدا قتلوه صح زين ولا حدا سجن ولا يعني
مش بس هيك بعد سنوات رجعوا وزروهم صاروا
وزراء
فرصه نعم
بكثير من العيوب والنواقص
[موسيقى]